vous avez pas et goût à la cuisine que
vous faites est ce que quand votre femme
sera rendrait vous me direz tient ce
soir je vais faire la cuisine
peut-être prudemment non pas lui donner
une mauvaise habitude
bon la vaisselle vous la faites vous
même un oui mais en bloc et
j'attends qui est vraiment à sa grotte
assure l'ailier nathan des communes
jours non je ne sais pas je veux pas
chercher à savoir actuellement est ce
que vous êtes en vie en mesure de me
dire qu'on veille à d'assiette empilés
dans votre évier ont pas du tout je veux
pas imaginer
chez vous les problèmes de ménage
abeilles en a pas il y en a demandé à ce
que votre problème non il n'ya pas de
ménage quand y'a pas de problème
alors lacoussière bas la poussière et
les gens voient pas beaucoup